when a president Trump's GOP critics
2012 presidential nominee Mitt Romney is
eyeing a new political opportunity to
represent Utah the longest-serving
Senate Republican Orrin Hatch says he's
going to retire after 42 years in
Washington
our sources expect the former
Massachusetts governor to run for
Hatch's Senate seat Nancy Cordes is on
Capitol Hill Nancy good morning good
morning several GOP sources tell CBS
News that Romney has been quietly laying
the groundwork in case hatch were to
retire and while he hasn't said anything
publicly about his intention to run take
a look at this this is a pretty good
clue yesterday afternoon Romney listed
his location on his Twitter profile as
Massachusetts but then after hatch
announced his plans to retire Romney's
profile location was updated to holiday
Utah every good fighter knows when to
hang up the gloves in a video posted on
Twitter orrin hatch referenced his early
days as an amateur boxer as he revealed
his plans to leave the political ring
after much prayer and discussion with
family and friends I've decided to
retire at the end of this term this was
a landmark day as chair of the Finance
Committee senator hatch spearheaded last
month's passage of GOP tax cuts and he
was one of the earliest senior
Republicans to support President Trump
mr. Trump no fan of mitt romney had
urged hatch to stay in the senate for an
eighth term you are a true fighter Trump
once had the same respect for Romney and
even considered him for Secretary of
State
despite Romney's frequent critiques of
him he's playing the members of the
American public for suckers
but the relationship has been a rocky
one and I said mitt cannot run he choked
like a dog
in August Romney urged the president to
apologize for his response to the deadly
Charlottesville protests
I think this blame on both sides Romney
wrote on Facebook that mr. Trump's words
caused racists to rejoice minorities to
weep and the vast heart of America to
mourn Romney congratulated hatch
yesterday on his 40-plus years in the
Senate saying senator hatch has
represented the interests of Utah with
distinction and honor hatch has appeared
to go back and forth about retiring over
the past few months partly because of
pressure from the White House to stay on
if Romney is running Nora he will likely
make his intentions known soon because
the election is this November all right
Nancy thank you I know there's also a
big meeting today between congressional
leaders and White House officials what's
on that big agenda into the Democrats
having leverage well they think they do
Congress needs to pass a bill to fund
the government by mid month they punted
on this issue when they were trying to
get out of the town out of town for the
holidays
Democrats want some kind of solution for
daca recipients young people came to
this country illegally in exchange for
their votes on government funding but
right now Republicans don't really
believe that they'd be willing to shut
the government down over that issue all
right Nancy thank you